haremos ahora el problema número 4 del
capítulo sobre extrusión normal que
aparece en el libro dsk 12 puntos org de
estadística de ap puedes ir al sitio web
y bajarlo es totalmente gratis
así que problema número 4 el cual es
desde el punto de vista una buena
práctica para una distribución normal o
más bien una distribución normal
estándar ubica los siguientes en orden
de menor a mayor el porcentaje de datos
abajo de uno al porcentaje de datos
abajo de menos uno dibujemos la gráfica
de la distribución normal estándar la
distribución normal estándar es aquella
en la cual la media el perdón este sigma
en las visiones estándar la media de
media la media es igual a 0 y la
desviación estándar es igual a 1 vamos a
dibujar entonces la distribución normal
estándar
aquí tenemos
nuestro eje x
y la voy a dibujar una bella curva de
campana
aquí la tenemos una curva de campana
tenemos que esta es una institución
normal estándar entonces la media
muestra aquí en el centro es una gráfica
que no es sesgada entonces esta es la
media igual a 0 y tenemos que la
división estándar es igual a 1 entonces
aquí tenemos una desviación estándar a
la derecha aquí tenemos dos desviaciones
estándar y aquí tres desviaciones
estándar ahora una desviación estándar a
la izquierda menos 12 desviaciones
estándar a la izquierda menos 23
desviaciones estándar menos 3 pues la
desviación estándar es igual a 1 veamos
si podemos responder la pregunta cuál es
el porcentaje de datos abajo de 1
entonces hagamos el inciso a porcentaje
de datos abajo de 1 es esta región abajo
de 1 no tan sólo esta porción central
sino toda esta región hasta acá es el
porcentaje de datos abajo de 1
y este es otro caso donde podemos
aplicar la regla empírica la regla
empírica no nos hace daño practicarla
nuevamente la regla empírica que también
podríamos decir que la regla del 68 95
99.7 yo digo que esta es una mejor
manera de denominar esta regla pues
estos son esencialmente los números que
tienes que memorizar digo si tienes una
calculadora o una tabla distribución
normal no tienes que memorizar esto pero
a veces en clase lo requieres y además
puedes impresionar a tus amigos
veamos si podemos utilizar esta regla
para contestar la pregunta el área
debajo de la curva de campana hasta el 1
o toda el área a la izquierda de 1 la
regla empírica nos dice que el área
comprendida entre menos una desviación
estándar
y una desviación estándar es igual al
68% esa es la regla empírica eso no lo
dice la regla empírica y lo vimos en un
vídeo previo también vimos en un vídeo
previo que la suma de toda el área tiene
que ser 1 es decir esta cola izquierda
esta zona sombreada sumada con esta zona
de acá más los 68 % tiene que sumar 1 o
100% entonces estas dos combinadas nos
dan igual a 32 por ciento 32 más 68 es
igual a 100 ahora esto es simétrico
estas dos sumadas dan 32 % por lo que
esto aquí es 16% y este de aquí es 16
por ciento también regresando a la
pregunta nos piden que encontremos el
área de todo déjame hacerlo con un nuevo
color de todo lo que es menor aún el
porcentaje de datos abajo de 1 es todo
lo que está a la izquierda de este punto
tenemos entonces que el 68% que es esta
porción central 68% que es esta porción
central entre -1 y una desviación
estándar más esta rama de la izquierda
que es igual a 16 por ciento 68% más de
6% es igual
89% así que este inciso a es 84%
eventualmente los vamos a tener que
ordenar pero ya hicimos la parte más
difícil una vez que tiene los números
ordenarlos es muy fácil parte de el
porcentaje de datos debajo de menos 1 el
porcentaje de datos debajo de menos 1 es
a la izquierda de este punto lo que nos
están pidiendo es esta área el
porcentaje de datos debajo de menos 1 el
cual es como ya lo calculamos igual a
16% y esto lo podías haber sabido
inclusive sin conocer la regla empírica
simplemente al ver la distribución
normal que esta área en total la de la
parte d es un subconjunto de la parte a
que va a ser un número menor por lo cual
si hubieras tenido que ordenar las cosas
podrías haber tenido es intuición inciso
sé cuál es la media eso es muy fácil la
media de distribución normal estándar
por definición es igual a cero la
respuesta al inciso se es cero
la desviación estándar bueno por
definición la desviación estándar de la
distribución normal estándar es igual a
1 esto es más fácil de lo que pensaba y
si psoe el porcentaje de datos arriba de
2 arriba de 2 nos piden el porcentaje de
datos arriba de 2 sabemos de la regla
6895 99.7 que si queremos conocer la
cantidad de datos que está dentro de dos
desviaciones estándar deja de hacerlo
con un nuevo color
aquí tenemos déjame agarrar un color más
llamativo vamos a hacerlo con verde
entonces si nos ubicamos en la porción
central de menos dos desviaciones
estándar a dos desviaciones estándar
esta área en total dentro de dos
desviaciones estándar por la regla
empírica es igual al 95% dentro de dos
desviaciones estándar esto es 95 por
ciento lo cual implica que todo lo que
está fuera de esa región todo lo que
está antes de desviaciones estándar y
después de dos desviaciones estándar
tomado en conjunto
todo lo que está fuera de dos
desviaciones estándar tiene que ser
igual pues lo que resta del 95% que es
igual a 5% si tú tomas en conjunto esta
cola y esta otra cola todo lo que está a
la izquierda de la derecha de dos
desviaciones estándar bueno con el mismo
argumento que usado todo es simétrico
por lo que esta área de aquí es igual a
2.5 por ciento y estaría de aquí también
es igual a 2.5 por ciento así que nos
piden el porcentaje de datos arriba de 2
es esta zona de aquí estas son en
amarillo la cual hemos calculado que es
igual a 2.5 por ciento el porcentaje de
datos arriba de 2 lo pongo con un color
oscuro es igual a 2.5 por ciento
la pregunta ubica los siguientes de
menor a mayor aquí hay una ambigüedad
porque nos piden el porcentaje de datos
abajo de 1 si nos piden el porcentaje de
datos abajo de 1 la respuesta es 84 pero
si nos piden la fracción de datos abajo
de 1 el resultado sería punto 84 depende
como el intérprete es lo mismo aquí si
te tiene el porcentaje de datos
abajo de -1 bueno el porcentaje de datos
es 16 pero si nos piden la fracción de
datos debajo de menos 1 la fracción
corresponde a punto 16 igual para este
inciso el porcentaje es 2.5 y las
fracciones punto 025 es el valor de la
fracción o el valor en decimales digo es
simplemente ordenar números así es que
no me debería fijar mucho en esto pero
supongamos que lo quieren hacer con
decimales entonces de menor a mayor el
número menor que tenemos aquí es 0 que
es el inciso c la media que es igual a 0
luego el siguiente número es punto 025
que es el inciso
luego seguimos con el inciso b que es 16
posteriormente es el inciso a 3.84 y
finalmente la desviación estándar que es
de cebat y obviamente el orden sería
distinto si la respuesta fuera por
ejemplo en vez de puntos 0 84 84 apuesta
estarían preguntando el porcentaje una
pregunta ambigua como este un examen lo
aclarar ya con el profesor bueno espero
que te haya sido útil